how's it going bros my name is rapper
and welcome to the Halloween update of
what if I legend out the brofist this
updates came out for you bros for free
so if you bought the game you can
download it it won't cost anything and
there's a cool update where you can
record yourself playing the game through
your iPhone device so you can be fortify
who doesn't want to do that
alright so as you can see I beat the
whole game I beat all game all by myself
did not cheat did not cheat so yeah if
you have the update and you came this
far you don't have to be doing the
hardest any difficulty you should see
this in your area let's play it so a
play is duck duck has my favorite
ability in the game so that should be
cool here we go I've never played this
level before so this is really fun I
don't know what's good I hate these
[ __ ] [ __ ]
Castlevania son of a [ __ ] so the duck
has its ability where he can fly which
is really helpful unless you suck at the
game
she says [ __ ] christ boots I just
want to say thanks to all the amazing
support in this game I'm like me and the
developers were blown away by how much
you loved this game and we wanted to do
this free update as a little thank you
for Halloween we will keep updating the
game but we will also add stuff that we
have a lot of plans we have a lot of
puns to say that I won't ask boil
anything Mac this is [ __ ] disgusting
what am i walking on music is awesome in
this level
- dokkum oh that's that's it duck mouth
all the way so a lot of people don't
know you have to hold okay I can't kiss
a goat if you have to hold down the jump
button to jump extra high a lot of
people seem to start up then oh god the
red barrels red ghost barrels [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
I'm speedrunning this [ __ ] Oh
God duck Murr I love my little duck Oh
No
go spiral no problem quickscope [ __ ]
your [ __ ]
ducking quick scope no scope 360 all day
Sun all date God just actually legit
creepy look at the background everything
[ __ ] awesome alright so hold on jump
are you [ __ ] kidding me I'm playing
on PC as well so they should be like
easier for me bad AB no no it's not it's
not easy nothing is easier if you're an
idiot life is just one big structure
people don't realize are you [ __ ]
alright so once I actually managed to
beat this level which might be never who
knows
I will show you another really awesome
thing part of the update it's not I
don't even have to hold down the yonk
button that's why I failed so I really
don't want to fail as duck because when
the ducklings die it's just the saddest
thing in life you see
a lemon see I clearly need more brokers
like how many brokers I have let's just
go let's go
bro each character has a new skin i got
uh kauai pads
marzia has dark Marzia she kind of looks
like the girl from Addams Family
markiplier is a pilot Ken gets his manly
bear and like what the [ __ ] is a call it
AB wood whatever
jack is the best one because he's a
[ __ ] leprechaun cry is a pirate it's
[ __ ] awesome and dark dark done
I'll show you look how I am my hair haha
I look like one of those trolls you had
as a kid my skirt is just blowing in the
wind so kawaai I want to do I want to do
jack not not like that
actually 100% like that this is so cute
aren't africana she ash that's very good
isn't it this is my Irish accent I'm
jook jook jook oi I love playing video
games and how does it top of the mornin
to ya lattice I am an Irish it's just
racist that's not it's not you can't I
wonder if we will do the dialogue though
hey man are you all right fresh game
ever so another thing that we have in
the game that you might not have seen
before is that this level the point of
this level is to just survive as long as
possible so I'm just gonna try and
survive as long as I can if you can beat
my if you can beat my high score of how
long you can survive to eat me at beat
beat the bro and I'll send you something
this outfit really fits my sex addiction
because she just died her hair darker so
I'm gonna ride Maya whoo Jesus Christ
are you kidding me oh [ __ ] the
Illuminati see I told you I'm not
Illuminati I told ya hey I don't want to
kill my girlfriend god no yeah seven
minutes we got to make it just seven
minutes if no but never mind never mind
all right
the 6:40 47 Wow take a screenshot tweet
at me if you can do better but that's it
that's a nice little free update for you
bros as a thank you for supporting this
game it's only available if you actually
bought the game we got a [ __ ] ton of
torrents and illegal downloads so we
really appreciate that you actually
support the game because that helps us
create more content and bring more stuff
for you so thank you so much and as
always stay awesome rush
al are they recreated my room like I
live in the time recording the tiniest
space ever it gets so [ __ ] hot I have
no ventilations I love that painting I
miss it